we're here today in the spiritual home
with the periodic videos to show you an
energetic reaction and I'm like the
normal energetic reactions that I show
you like with with oxygen and things
like that
5 4 3 2 1 we don't need a source of
ignition for this chemical reaction it's
called a hypergolic reaction so we take
two reactants and we mix them together
in the instantaneously form a chemical
reaction with a generation of lots of
heat exothermic reactions and lots of
small molecules of gas like co2 nitrogen
and stain so the hypergolic reactions
themselves are really really useful and
you find them all over the place in jet
mode motors and rockets and things like
that right now we're here very good but
we thought we'd show you what to do in
the lab so in a fume hood we've got a
small amount of equipment we have a
stand which we're going to use to to
contain our reaction and we're going to
do the reaction in a test tube and what
I've done is I've cooled the test you've
a nice so it's cold I'll tell you why
I'm going to do that now so I'm going to
clamp it up and then lower it so that
it's steady okay so you can see it quite
nicely
now I've cooled it quite simply because
one of the reactants in this hypergolic
reaction is normally a gas at room
temperature it boils at about 21 degrees
so on a warm day like today and
Nottingham like 24 degrees it's a gas so
as I said it's a gas stored in a
cylinder and here's our cylinder of n2o4
okay it's quite an energetic mixture and
we're going to use it as an oxidant for
for this hypergolic reaction so we're
going to put some in the tube so
open the valve open second file slowly
and allow the gas to dribble into the
test tube
if I hold the test tube up you can see
that there's a very nice orange liquid
in the bottom and it's vaporizing
informative quite a heavy gas dense gas
which is sitting above the liquid so
there's our oxidant the first component
of our hypergolic mixture
the second component or the fuel for
this chemical reaction is there it's got
a common molecule it's one that's used
in in the laboratories all the time in
its aniline so this is a benzene ring
with a nitrogen group hanging off the
side okay so the aniline will react with
the the n2o5 n2o4 and then we will
generate lots of co2 lots of nitrogen
I'm going to steam water vapor so here
I'm going to take a pipette which we've
made specially for this reaction and I'm
going to add a small amount of the
aniline to the test tube and hopefully
we'll see a hypergolic
so pet approximately a milliliter of
Annalee into the pipette and then we'll
add a few drops and see what happens so
as you can see is the millet that I put
the aniline in it reacts spontaneously
to generate lots of smoke which you can
see here is carbon lots of co2 nitrogen
and water vapor I think we should try it
a little bit more
again the reaction proceeds very nicely
a little bit faster now because the tube
is already warm let's try for a third
now the n2o4 is all used